Want a soda?
This'll cost you
more in Philadelphia because
politicians there
voted to tax these.
Ayes are 13,
the nays are 4.
Listen to the applause.
The sugar sweet beverage tax.
There was more applause when the bill was signed.
The politicians said the tax will
fund early childhood education.
This would be great for this community
and to help a lot of families.
But store owners say,
"It's a bad tax."
Melvin Robinson,
who runs Bruno's Pizza says
the soda tax is killing
his business.
What do your customers say?
What'd they say?
They're not buying it.
I refuse
to buy soda in Philadelphia.
Well, a 20 ounce soda almost 3 dollars.
So instead of buying at Bruno's,
they cross the street
because Bruno's is located
right on the outer edge
of Philly.
So I gotta get a soda or a juice.
I'll go
right across the street.
Right. These customers
just cross the street,
save a buck.
When I want something to drink I go right there.
But he comes here
for the pizza.
Yeah yeah,
they got the best slice in town.
But the soda tax still
punishes Melvin.
This happens whenever local governments impose
special new taxes.
Like who
should pay three dollars for a drink
that they used to get for 99 cents?
If customers can escape,
they will.
Do the politicians think about that ?
So a buck more
for one of these?
It definitely is more,
but it's for
what we feel is a good reason
for a good cause.
City Councilman William Greenlee says
Philadelphia needs the tax money.
Nothing else that we could come up with
could raise that kind of funding.
But soda taxes are
disproportionately paid by poor people.
Even so-called progressives
campaigned against this tax.
You don't have to fund child care
on the backs of the poorest people in this city.
That's a regressive way to raise funds.
It hits the poor most.
Even Bernie Sanders
opposes this tax.
I didn't know Bernie opposed it but okay.
Remember we're raising enough money
to put 2700 kids in
Pre-K and to open 11 community schools.
The pizza parlor's customers
didn't think their taxes
were being well-spent.
Preschool?
I doubt that very much.
The mayor says he's helping people.
He ain't helping me.
He's tearing me up.
Meanwhile,
taxes create unintended consequences.
Soda sales are way down.
But sales of more harmful products are up.
Now some people are buying more liquor,
less Coke, more liquor.
I don't know about that
because we have a liquor tax too so....
Politicians love taxes on unhealthy things
and so do the media.
They applauded when Denmark taxed fatty food.
Denmark has decided to implement
what they're calling a fat tax.
Basically you go to the supermarket,
you buy a food that has above a certain level of fat,
they charge you extra.
Alright,
do we feel good about this, Doc?
Absolutely.
But Danes just crossed the border
to shop in other countries.
Within a year,
Denmark repealed its fat tax.
But Philadelphia isn't repealing
anything.
People in this town already pay
44 taxes.
State income tax,
sales tax,
cigarette and alcohol taxes.
Philadelphia has a very high income tax
compared to other places.
How can you not have enough money?
The wage tax is high.
You should be rolling in money.
Oh I don't know about that.
But there's a lot to do out there, John.
4 million for the
Office of Arts and Culture
Mm-hmm.
Funded two sessions of dance instruction,
teach youth empowerment,
social issues through hip hop.
Office of Arts and Culture
does a very good job in the city of Philadelphia.
Like we need that.
They're funding the Arts.
What Arts?
People trying to live.
Politician says "We gotta raise money."
Stop stealing.
That would be nice.
I don't know that he's stealing, but
he pays himself 121 thousand bucks a year.
Wow.
You make $121,000 a year,
three times what the
median income
of what your citizens make.
Well, I don't think that's terribly unusual
for elected officials.
Sadly he's right.
Politicians routinely make much more
than the people they allegedly serve.
A lot of citizens should make more money,
you know.
Well they can't make more money
when you're taxing them to death.
Well, I don't think we're taxing them to death.
The politicians
always want more
and the restaurants,
they just have to pay.